how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and everything relating to the
mcu and today we have some pretty big
but
pretty sad news the pandemic strikes
again and we have some more delays
with the marvel phase 4 schedule in the
marvel cinematic universe
now unfortunately this is kind of
expected at this point in time
theaters are having a hard time opening
back up although more and more theaters
do seem to be opening
however the box office results aren't
exactly what studios want to see at this
point in time
so marvel studios has delayed three
movies including black widow
the eternals and shang chi and the
legend of the ten rings
so here are the new theatrical release
dates for these three movies
black widow was supposed to come out on
november 6th this
year but now it has been pushed back to
may 7th of 2021
almost a year pushback from its original
release date and then we have the
eternals which was supposed to debut on
february 12th
of 2021 but now is set to premiere in
theaters november
5th of 2021. shang chi and the legend of
the 10 rings was originally supposed to
be on may 7th of 2021 but has now moved
only to july 9th of 2021. and this is
very interesting because shang chi
and the legend of the ten rings is
actually coming out before
the eternals now shengshi only got
pushed back a couple of months but the
eternals got pushed back
close to a year the order was supposed
to go black widow
the eternals shang chi but now it goes
black widow
shang chi and the eternals now of course
marvel studios's decision to delay these
movies comes from several different
reasons of course the pandemic shut down
their current projects that they were
working on
and that included shang chi but black
widow and the eternals have actually
been done for a while
but of course marvel studios connects
all of their different movies and shows
now together
so the delay of black widow obviously
pushes some other movies back as well
but it seems like the eternals won't
really have that much of an effect or
connection to shang chi
as it is now coming out after so marvel
studios is kind of doing things a little
bit differently
and unfortunately we're going to have to
wait a little bit longer to find out
what exactly they're doing
so be sure to subscribe so you can stay
up to date on all the latest news
including all these delays and new
theatrical release dates also so you can
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win a scarlet witch
funko pop all you gotta do is subscribe
like the video and leave a comment down
below
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof